so first I want to talk about the goal
of this talk what do we want to
accomplish and I want everyone in here
the feel like regardless of their
experience level if they feel just kind
of like okay at JavaScript if they have
three or four hours worth of tutorials
of react under their belt I want them to
feel like they can play around with
aetherium solidity and react and kind of
like start building your own
decentralized application this isn't
some like dark arts like wizardry right
this is just kind of like new and
different tech and to do that I want to
provide everyone with mhk minimal
hacking knowledge I want you to be a
have a basic enough understanding of the
concept of aetherium smart contracts and
all the tools you need to start hacking
away on either my project or your
project and to accomplish this we're
gonna divide the talk into three areas
the first is we're gonna talk about the
idea of blockchain etherium and smart
contracts if you're unfamiliar with all
that I got you covered
the second part of the talk is we're
gonna talk about all the tools you need
to get rockin and rollin and finally
we're gonna have our own little sample
project and what will learn is
blockchain theorem and smart contracts
how aetherium is different than a
traditional blockchain like Bitcoin
we're gonna go over all the tools and
frameworks you need to get started we're
gonna go over solidity which is
currently the most popular language or
aetherium compiling we're gonna go over
a sample hello world project and then
we're gonna go over react components
with aetherium and web 3 and how to kind
of interact with it through react
components and finally for all the
testing fans out there we're gonna go
over how you can actually test your
smart contract so first let's talk about
the idea or blockchain a crash course we
have a lot to cover probably any one of
these subjects we could spend over an
hour talking about so I'm gonna give you
the basics so hold onto your butts I
want to say what we won't cover we're
not gonna go down into the weeds too
much we're not going to go over
cryptography
proof of steak versus proof of work
we're not gonna go over to Byzantine
generals problem etc but I feel like I
will provide you with enough of a basic
understanding that you get the core
concepts so first let's talk about the
Internet as it is or the Internet of
information and it was created the
transmitted information
anything that can stored digitally text
images movies created to transmit that
so let's take an mp3 for example now
here we have this shady little person
with mp3 and I know everyone here is a
responsible citizen of the internet and
back in college would never share an mp3
but let's look at this little guy right
here and let's say he shares that mp3 to
two people now those two people can save
copy distribute information to other
people and they can do it to other
people and so on and so on so that
single mp3 now becomes millions of mp3s
that are indistinguishable between one
another to exact same copy now let's
talk about the Internet as it could be
or the internet of value and the
blockchain had a transmit value okay so
let's go back to the mp3 example so here
we have that one person with an mp3 and
they sent it to person B a person a no
longer has access to it it can transmit
to someone else but they no longer can
manipulate it and person B sends it to
person C and the previous two people no
longer have access to it and a good
example of how to deal with transmitting
value of course is money and payment
systems you've probably heard a Bitcoin
but how does this accomplish
well it's accomplished through something
called a ledger and a ledger just
records all transactions and keeps
up-to-date info on who owns what and how
much each block is a series each block
contains the history of the block ie the
blockchain and you can think of each
block is representing the current state
of the blockchain and since we're
dealing a lot with state you know it
might be a good idea to deal with a
framework that deals a lot with state
intent
all right so let's check out some of the
awesome benefits of this well first its
decentralized right no single party can
manipulate the ledger we do not provide
any centralized person with trust it's
immutable you cannot go back into the
past and change transactions and my
personal favorite is that it's
permissionless anyone can join and start
adding and confirming transactions all
right there's no walled garden there's
no central authority saying who can join
and what they can do anyone can do it
and if we take a basic operation let's
say person a wants to send person B some
Bitcoin right they want to send 0.25
Bitcoin
well we'll subtract that 0.25 add that
2.5 and once that block is confirmed
person a has 0.75 and person B as 0.25
all right and but that's just still a
basic ledger right all we're doing is
adding of subtracting values from
different accounts but what if we wanted
to go beyond money and record all value
and this is where aetherium enters so
it's still a ledger but now it's a
programming language on top of a ledger
so the distributed ledger now becomes a
distributed computer which is called the
etherium virtual machine and we're gonna
go over this here in a little bit all
right so we could transmit the value of
not just kind of money but we could
transmit the value of copyrighted
material like an mp3 example real estate
property insurance legal contracts
supply chains identity we can choose who
we want to share our identity with and
how much and a whole lot or a lot of
cool applications so now let's talk
about
aetherium smart contracts and you first
aetherium versus ether what's the
difference well aetherium is just the
etherium virtual machine and ether is
the currency of aetherium I put a little
ass trick there because it's not a true
currency like you think of Bitcoin we're
gonna go that here in a second
so the etherium virtual machine what is
that
well the EBM or aetherium virtual
machine is a sandboxed virtual stack
machine embedded with an each full
aetherium node responsible for executing
contract bytecode what does that mean
well it means that each smart contract
is executed through byte code within
each node of the etherium network ether
what's ether well we said ether is kind
of like the currency of aetherium but
it's more accurately a utility currency
it's what powers the etherium virtual
machine and how does it do this it's
does this through a concept called gas
all right now gas it's just the ether
that fuels etherium every transaction on
etherium costs a little bit of ether to
use but more importantly it's related to
etherium coating each computational step
in aetherium contract for example each
function cost a fixed number of gas to
use but gas price is dynamic and a term
by the market so you can kind of check
this out at F gas station that info and
this is pretty cool you can get an idea
of like how much will cost to like
perform a certain action depending on
the market and since each step costs a
fixed number of gas to use the more
complex or bloated code the more
expensive it becomes to transmit that
transaction and this is why performance
in smart contract programming is so
important because poor performing smart
contracts literally cost you more money
now as an example let's say you have a
picture of your beautiful Puritan family
and you want to store on the blockchain
forever because you love them so much
and it's one megabyte big well back when
aetherium costs $295 it would take over
$5,000 and take over 100 steps to
eventually get it on the blockchain
because each block can only use so much
gas and this is an example of why you
know storing things on aetherium is not
really an optimal solution some people
are trying to solve this just as an
aside through a distributed file system
by storing a hash representing ownership
of file which is pretty cool
and this is all stored in
bytecode which is what solidity the
language are going to talk about to use
to write our smart contracts compiles
down into and we're not to go into the
weeds yet just yet but just know
bytecode is coming up I also wanted to
talk about tokens very briefly we're not
going to go into tokens but it's usually
what people are most familiar with when
talking about aetherium I just what kind
of like want to expose people to the
idea the commonly called ERC 20 and all
it is it's just a standard for how to
interact with a smart contract and it's
its own entity stored on top of the
etherium blockchain an e rc just stands
for aetherium requests for comments and
that's just an official protocol for
proposing improvements to the main
etherium network and 20 is just the
unique proposal ID number so that's all
that means some examples of some tokens
0x project which is a permissionless
protocol for decentralized exchanges so
no more centralized acceding hacking
Aragon which is a decentralized
organization through an open governance
model and open governance is something
I'm pretty interested in district 0x
which is a network of these centralized
markets and communities which is
actually built on top of Aragon so you
can have ERC 20s that are dependent on
ERC 20s that are dependent on aetherium
which is kind of cool and fun fair which
is just you know something that its
offering fair transparency and increased
security for online gambling and there's
just hundreds of these things those are
kind of like some cool ones there's also
one called NERC 721 which is non
fungible token what does that mean well
each token is unique and non divisible
with its own characteristics example of
this is digital collectables such as
crypto kitties if you've heard of that
that's basically just a way to breed
sell and buy your own cats and now that
we kind of have some of the core
concepts about theorem and blockchain
let's go into develop time alright so
first I want to give it a little bit of
warding all right right now the
documentation sucks easier doesn't exist
it's outdated
it can be contradictory there's few best
practices as of now there's little
information on what tools to use to
actually work with it hopefully we can
solve that today and breaking changes
can and probably will happen when
updating or even working with it but I
want to say don't panic all right that
might seem a little discouraging but to
me it's kind of like really exciting
right we're like an unexplored territory
it's completely open because a lot of
people don't even like know what they're
doing which is pretty cool to me so for
our next part of our talk I want to talk
about the tools we need to get rockin
and rollin and I want to say like I made
this on my macbook this presentation is
sample project but I also have a similar
set up working on my Linux computer so
just so you know that it's working on
both of those and the first tool you
need is something called ganache
what is ganache what allows us to have a
local block chain test net environment
and it's really cool people used to use
and I used to use test RPC which is a
command line tool and I want to say I'm
a big fan of the command line I prefer
the command line but don't use test our
PC because ganache is way better just
use the GUI it's pretty awesome and when
you open ganache this is what you see
right you'll get a bunch of tabs at the
top that give you some options to kind
of view what's going on and then you'll
be provided with 10 accounts each with a
hundred ether and that's plenty to play
around with and do your own testing and
have fun with if you click on blocks you
can see which block was mined if a
transaction was on that block how much
gas was used for each block for that
transaction you can see transactions
transaction hash which is basically just
a receipt of a transaction you can see
contract calls contract creations and
also making though under the options
right I see right there at then at the
bottom you see Auto mine ganache is set
up to out of mine automatically so any
time it senses a transaction it'll just
mine that next block and store that
transaction on there and I like that
whenever I'm kind of working with the
smart contract directly that way it's
kind of like super fast and see what's
going on
things work but whenever I switched to
the UI and I want to kind of like see
how a user would interact with it I like
to give it a mining block time in
seconds because that kind of simulates
how user would actually deal with a
deployed contract right now the actual
average time for a deployed contract I
mean for a block in the etherium main
network is averaging around 14 seconds I
want to make a note there's a couple
things we got to remember going forward
all right so back at the topic and nosh
you'll see this thing called RPC server
alright so make a note of that we're
gonna need that both for meta mask and
truffle which are two tools coming up
and then also after each account is a
little key icon and that will give you
access to your private keys if you don't
know what private keys are anyone that
owns a private key for a theory amad
ress basically has complete control of
all the ether inside that account so you
always want to keep that private but for
our test net you know where it's gonna
be playing around with it second tool
you need is a browser extension called
meta mask and this is kind of like one
of the secret sauces we need in order to
make our decentralized application work
in the browser it enables users to
interact with aetherium enabled websites
via the web 3 javascript api which is
pretty cool right you can interact with
the main aetherium network through your
browser I think that's pretty cool some
of the browser works on our Chrome
Firefox Opera brave it does not work on
Safari or Internet Explorer but who
cares about those browsers so you just
install it like you would any other
extension right at extension and you're
gonna create your own account here and I
want to say that I used a minim ask beta
for these next set of images because
they're super close to revamping their
UI and this is what it's gonna look like
so in order to like kind of extend a
longevity of this talk I wanted to use
the updated UI but if you use the
original all the steps are exactly the
same it just looks a little bit
different now you may be tempted right
underneath create UC import of seed
phrase if you're familiar seed phrase is
just the way to recover accounts and
ganache provides you one right here
under rheumatic don't do this
all right because the reason is is that
you may think I'm only gonna be using
this for development but what's
interesting this is pretty hilarious is
that a lot of people accidentally import
that ganache account right and if you
have access to that C phrase every
single scene phrase when you download
ganache is exactly the same so any
person who's ever download ganache has
access to those private keys right and
since private keys are complete access
to ether anyone has access to it so if
you accidentally send ether on the main
network to that ganache account and you
think you're just in your test Network
someone has actually set up a script to
automatically withdraw ether from that
account and deposit it to an account
they have complete control over so some
of so many people have just messed up
just flubbing out this person's
collected over half an e fare just from
like random mistakes which is pretty
interesting so to use blah blah blah
Blee hashtag all right
so guess what in your browser you're now
connected to the main aetherium network
which is pretty cool but we want to get
on our local test net so what do we do
under main network in the top right
click that click them click custom RPC
and remember how I said and ganache pay
attention to that server address right
there we just copy paste that click Save
next thing we want to do is we want to
import our accounts remember I said pay
attention to that key icon after a count
one well there's our private key we're
gonna copy paste that paste that account
and guess what that's pretty awesome
right we're on our private network it's
reading how much ether we have through
our web browser which is pretty cool the
next tool we need is a framework called
truffle and truffle is currently the
most popular development framework for
aetherium you need nodejs and NPM for
this I won't go over how to install that
if you're not familiar with that but I
have a link in the readme on my repo
about how to do that we want to install
this globally so NPM stall that's G
truffle and next we're gonna do truffle
unbox reacts
so what does that do well truffle has
this concept of boxes to integrate the
truffle framework with other frameworks
and since we're using react when I
started react was the only option but
now they have all kinds of boxes to pick
whatever you want to be familiar with or
whatever you're more comfortable with
like view angular nodejs all sorts of
cool options and I also want to say as
an aside if you would do truffle on buy
ox reacts and you get this error don't
panic me and some other people in the
issue queue or having this error right
now but it still works fine it's some
outdated dependencies don't worry about
it
alright so we unboxed react ready to go
first thing we need to do is truffle
compile alright because every react box
comes with a sample project okay so what
does truffle compile do truffle compile
takes our smart contract compiles it
down to bytecode for the EVM for theory
and virtual machine to understand next
thing what I do is truffle migrate what
is truffle migrate do it migrates our
compiled bytecode onto our development
network but when you do truffle migrate
when you just start a react box uh-oh
you're gonna get an error no network
specify I cannot determine a network so
why don't forget to have ganache running
we need our local test nut running to in
our directory there you have a truffle
dot J's file and you'll see it has a
little message there saying hey under
advanced configuration you need to set
up your truffle network even though
every project needs this it's under
advanced for whatever reason but it's
not that bad
also in that directory is truffle -
config dot J s that's strictly for
Windows if you're not using Windows feel
free to delete that but just like our
RPC server we set up with meta mask
we're gonna set this up again in truffle
we're saying hey go to this host use
this port if you do truffle migrate
again guess what it works alright sweet
and you know this works not only from
the feedback that you get from the
command line but if you go back to
cannot guess what we no longer have
100 ether why is that remember how I
said every transaction every
computational step in aetherium cost a
little bit of ether to use and that's
another indicator that hey this is
successfully deployed to our test net
the included smart contract we're gonna
go over our own smart contract and
solidity because I think mine's a little
bit better honestly but we won't be
paying attention to it right now
but feel free to delete simple storage
but I want to make a note they keep
migrations right don't delete that
because that handles all of our
migrations MPM run start guess what
you're good to go
sweet now I want to talk about solidity
alright and solidity compiles the code
for the etherium virtual machine so
let's check out a basic overview of what
it does and how it does this and I want
to say that the language isn't tied to
aetherium other languages can be used
the important thing to understand is
that solidity and any language that will
come after it will always compile down
into the byte code which is why I beyond
understanding the byte code it's pretty
cool and important to understand if
you're more familiar with Python there's
a language called Viper that you can use
we're gonna go over solidity because I
come from JavaScript background and
we're gonna see how similar JavaScript a
little bit first thing about solidity
all right it's statically typed okay
come from a JavaScript background you'll
use var store data or const stored data
here we need to say what type of
variable is so for in this example using
uni tea which stands for unsigned
integer all that means is an integer of
positive value contracts and solidity
are similar to classes and
object-oriented languages so contract
simple storage and it's a similar
javascript right in fact that people
created solidity very intentionally
designed it around the Ekman script
syntax to make it familiar to existing
web developers aka everyone in this
audience
there's structs which are similar to
objects it also has mappings and
solidity can be thought of to two things
State and functions
and remember I said each block
represents the current state of the
entire blockchain well here we go right
state are pieces of information that are
permanently stored on the blockchain and
functions do things we can also have a
constructor which is the same name as
our contract and it's executed once when
the contract is deployed but solidity
like what does it really do its compiler
remember how we kept talking about byte
code well guess what here's byte code
the part that is executable by the evm
and this is what it looks like when you
program your smart contract and you do
truffle compile this is what it comes
down into right it looks crazy but the
interesting thing is each one of those
sets of numbers actually has a
corresponding opcode all right these op
codes are the Act the exec functions
that are actually executed by the EVM so
if you see 30 you know that you're
getting the address of the currently
executing account if you see 31 you know
you're getting the balance of any given
account so all Salone does is take a
higher-level language and then compile
it down into these our project the
preview from the whole world project
Oren talked about a little bit this is
all compiles down into so let's take a
look at like what's going on here 60 60
40 50 to store 60 in memory location 40
save word to memory what does that do
you don't need to know all right don't
worry about it but I kind of find
looking at off codes
super interesting right it's kind of
cool you don't need to know what's
actually going on but I think it's
important to know that hey slowly takes
your program and compiles it down into
byte code and those op codes are where
you get your fixed gasp amount for how
much a certain function requires I also
want to talk about security very briefly
it's too big to go into here but he may
have heard of contract hacking and I
just want to like provide you with a
couple things that will be in the slides
on the repo but every execution is a
smart contract publicly visible couple
lengths of security considerations and
best practices and as an aside I want to
mention like for anybody that's like
into security in this audience or
watching online it's pretty cool there's
been some kind of like open source
cloak-and-dagger bidding
going on with honey pots and what people
are doing is they're making contracts
with very well known bugs that will
allow anyone to kind of access a theory
theory ether stored in a contract so
let's say you know you're checking out
some publicly available contracts and
you see this bug right and you see that
contract stores a lot of ether and it
only costs a certain amount of ether to
interact with it so you say sweet free
ether I'm gonna interact with it exploit
that bug get that ether but what they're
doing is they're making that exploitable
part of the contract dependent on
another contract that closes that bug
takes your ether away so I think that's
pretty cool all right so let's actually
get started in our project all right
what are we gonna do first we're gonna
deploy our contract on our test net
second we're gonna see our predefined
hello a message stored on a blockchain
and then three we're gonna take our user
input from our react component to change
our message store it on a blockchain
retrieve it and update our state and
react don't forget all right anytime
you're starting one of these projects
you need to follow six steps and I had
this in the readme
but the things you need to do start
ganach our local blockchain test nut to
unlock meta mask and make sure local
network is selected switch accounts to
the one we imported shuffle compile
which compiles our smart contract down
into bytecode truffle migrate which
takes that bytecode and deploys it on
our test net and npm run start so our
contract alright react box comes with i
a simple storage all you do is got to
blow it out just rename it do whatever
you want with it and then change an app
GS what we want to import and our build
and here's our contracts alright it's
pretty straightforward all it's going to
do is a little hello world message but I
want everyone here to be comfortable
with solidity it doesn't matter how much
experience you have so I'm gonna go over
every line here let you know what's
going on alright so first pragma
solidity what is that that's known as
the version pragma and this allows us to
specify which version of solidity we
want to compile with so it's not to
introduce breaking changes in the future
when slowly updates then we have
contract hello world
that's kind of like just the complete
wrapping thing for our entire contract
and in string hello remember how I said
Lily was statically typed instead of
saying bar hello cause hello we're
letting the compiler know this is a type
of string and then we have a constructor
hello equals hello world we're setting
our global variable B hello world public
means anyone can interact with it then
we have our set hello and this is gonna
be how people are able to change our
hello world message function set hello
string hello for a function argument and
you notice I have it underscored here
and that's kind of a popular convention
and solidity is to underscore function
arguments to differentiate between
global variables it's up to you whether
or not you want to do this but it's
popular convention so I want to confuse
anyone that's why I'm doing it here and
in public so anyone is able to change
this so hello our global variable equals
underscore hello our function argument
and then get hello public view returns
string return hello all right public
anyone can interact with it
view it's basically like a constant
which is actually what that keyword was
originally called and all it means is it
indicates that the function will not
alter the storage state in any way all
this all this is is a getter so we're
not altering the storage State so we're
using view here and don't forget anytime
you work with solidity you make a change
guess what we need to recompile that
bytecode it's different now so truffle
compile and then we need to deploy that
contract on to our local test net
truffle migrate if you check out our app
Jess
what I did was I kept it super super
similar to a standard react box I want
anyone that plays around with my repo to
have a very easy time transitioning to a
standard react box so everything's gonna
be very very similar and we need to do
five things here first we need to import
everything we need need to set our
initial State we need to get web 3 and
I'll talk about what three in a second
you just an she ate our contract render
out our HTML and components and give you
a little preview if you kind of run this
when you download it this is what it
looks like yay all right I'll give you
your contract address it'll give you our
predefined hello world message which is
an arsenal
contract if you want to change the
message I'm gonna take user input here
hello Nashville meta mask will
automatically come up when you hit
submit which is how we confirm our
transaction to our local aetherium
network cost about 3 cents remember
every transaction either cost aetherium
cost a little bit easier to use hit
confirm I have a little cool indicator
here to let you know that we're waiting
on the latest block to mine and I want
to say like just from a UX perspective
you probably don't want to do like me
and have a modal covering your entire
site maybe like a little indicator in
the corner but our site can literally
only do one thing so I think it's kind
of fun to have a modal up there and then
once that block is mined our transaction
is confirmed we update our state which
is pretty awesome I think now you may be
sitting there being like Ryan I've been
sitting here for 40 minutes and all
you're doing is just replacing texts
like wow you know but like the cool
thing is is that you know it's not
exactly what the users see is all the
cool things that's happening behind the
scenes alright all the invisible stuff
so we're taking user input passing it to
our smart contract signing a transaction
in meta mask broadcasting that
transaction to the network storing it on
the blockchain then getting that message
and updating our state with it which is
pretty cool alright so how will you
accomplish this first we need to import
everything we need this is pretty much a
standard react box the only difference
here is I have my own hello well
contract and I have two custom
components contract input and modal we
have an initial state here again very
similar to stay in a react box we're
gonna get web 3 now what's web 3 alright
and this is another kind of like secret
thing alright it's very love web three
it's very cool and this is the etherium
compatible JavaScript API the
implemented generic JSON RPC spec
alright so what does that do well
enables us to work with aetherium
through JavaScript alright
if you console.log web 3 you're gonna
get all sorts of cool stuff all right
you can see you can get the accounts you
can get the block number you can get gas
price all sorts of cool stuff and then
we need to instantiate our contract
right again
very similar to a standard react box but
I feel like it's important to explain
what's going on
with hello world not deployed right in
the middle over there and basically this
is a JavaScript promise if you're not
familiar of promises all it is is a way
to handle a circus code you can think of
it as hay a way to do this and then do
that once we have this then do this
so we're saying hey once our smart
contract is deployed then do this so
then take an instance of our hello world
contract set our state you know make
that instance our hello world contract
then set the state for a contract
address if you remember how we did that
in the little preview I displayed the
smart contract address and then check
out what's going on right below that
right return hello world instance that
get hello well guess what that is our
solidity function in JavaScript we're
just using javascript to execute the
functions we're writing in solidity
which is pretty awesome
I think then take the result of get
hello and then update our state this
that says state hello equals result so
we're using javascript to work with
solidity which is pretty cool if you
console.log our contract you get all
kinds of cool information like ABI which
is our application binary interface and
this is just the interface available to
users across the network so they can see
what methods are available for them to
work with we can see get hello and set
hello or available we can see our
contract address and then down the
bottom we have render and this is all
this is just some standard markup here
standard react markup I only have two
custom components here modal contract
input
there's nothing dependent and modal to
go over our contract so I just want to
kind of like check out contract input so
let's check out contract input that Jas
what's going on here first we just have
standard element form element here we're
taking input and saying is this message
so the user input is going to be called
message and then I have an on submit
method called submit what does submit do
what's saying hey get that message value
alright or user input and then we have
two functions here set hello request and
get hello requests all right now these
are async await functions are very
similar to JavaScript promises or just
saying hey wait to do this first before
you execute so we're running get hello
first
what does that do alright so it's saying
Const result equals a weight set hello
request this props update hello result
what does that mean well it's saying hey
wait on a result from set hello request
so let's see what set hello request does
all right so we're taking a little hard
to see but hopefully you can saying
result equals instance that set hello
instances are smart contract we're again
we're using a function rewrote in our
smart contract and slowly set hello so
we pass in our message our user value
from web 3f accounts 0 and remember how
I said every transaction and aetherium
cost a little bit of ether or gas to use
so somebody's got to pay for this for
changing our hello world message and
ethic counts 0 is our standard meta mask
account so I'll be the first account
that we're using so that's who's gonna
pay for it then once we have the result
close the modal and return get Hello
whatever that is whatever they change
the message to return result and guess
what it'll update our state which is
pretty cool I also want to mention that
you can do tests in solidity for all the
time of testing fans out there you can
either write tests in solidity or
JavaScript I wrote it in JavaScript
because I'm Way more familiar JavaScript
and solidity so let's check this out
it's written jest and this is all it
does so let's check out what this
actually is doing at the very top art
effects that require and this all this
is is saves your ABI bytecode and other
contract related information in a JSON
file and then we have our contract name
Oh a world we're passing an accounts and
then we're just saying hey it should
what we will expect it to do well it
should set and get the hello world value
and then just like in our app J s file
we're saying have a JavaScript function
here it says hey when hello world is
deployed then do this alright so we're
passing in an instance of a whole world
contract then we're saying hey hello
world instance set hello all right so
we're setting the message to B this is a
hello test from account 0 someone's
gonna pay for it then return hello world
instance get hello call to execute get
hello me
immediately then what does that result
we're calling it stored data so assert
that equal stored data is this is a
hello test alright so if everything goes
fine guess what cool
we got a passing test we wrote a test in
JavaScript that works with solidity
which is compiled down to bytecode which
is pretty cool all right so we're not a
lot of time but I want to talk about
deployment all right so everyone here
should be kind of like familiar with the
standard web deployment you got local
development and production in ethereal
it's local test net and the main
ethereal Network there's all kinds of
different test nets like Rob's didn't
Cove in rinkeby I like rinkeby because I
find it to be pretty stable and it's
really easy to get test ether through a
github account and guess what theory I'm
gonna react right it's not so scary
isn't it I mean you can use JavaScript
to work with etherium which is pretty
cool so check it out what do we learn
well we learned about blockchain you
learned about theorem and smart
contracts how it's kind of a different
kind of blockchain with programming
language built on top of it we learned
about the tools and frameworks you need
like ganache medica mask truffle the
basis of solidity how its aesthetically
typed language we learned about our
sample hello world project and using a
react component to execute a function
that meta mask will used a broadcast and
transaction and then we learned about
how to write tests in JavaScript for
solidity I want to say don't forget
twitter.com slash hot pizzas please
download repo and fun with to ask me
questions yeah so check that out and
with that I just want to say thank you
all
[Applause]